We might take some inspiration for how human
beings solve this problem; we're very good
at understanding and operating in the three
dimensional world. In fact human beings use
a large number of different techniques, tricks,
sometimes called visual cues, to understand
three-dimensional structure.
Nine of them have been identified in this
particular paper. Different cues operate in
different distance regimes. Thought there
are some that are effective within our arms
reach, some are effective up to tens of meters
and some are effective right out to the horizon,
a distance of many kilometres.
Let's have a look at some of these visual
cues. The simplest of all is occlusion, and
this information comes from what object is
in front of another object. We can tell here
that the cat is in front of the brick gatepost
because the cat blocks out of obscures some
of that gatepost and the flowers are in front
of the cat because they block out some of the cat.
Another important cue is height in the visual
field. Looking at this we can see a tree and
we know a tree's a pretty big thing. But in
this particular image the tree does not look
that big, so therefore we figure that the
tree must be a long way away.
We also have relative size. Here we have a
number of trees. In our brain there's probably
some sort of logic that says that these are
trees, trees are all going to be the same
size, so therefore, this tree which looks
bigger than the other tree must be closest to us.
In these eye catching pictures, our brain
is momentarily confused. It takes a moment
for us to figure out what are the small things
that are close to the camera and what are
the large things that are far away from the
camera.
Here's a picture of a large stone in the desert
and just looking at it, it's rather hard for
us to gauge in any sort of absolute way, how
big this stone is and we can break the illusion
by introducing something who's size we know;
a pair of fingers and we can pick this stone
up and we can compare it to its more famous
big brother, the largest stone in the world,
called Uluru in the centre of Australia.
Here we see a very, very powerful illusion.
But nothing about this room is, as it seems.
For a start the floor is not flat. Now follow
me in and see what it looks like from the
inside. The clock is not actually round; if
we look at those square floor tiles we see
that they are not actually square. And the
corners of the room are not right angles.
The whole geometry of the room has been contrived,
so that from this one particular viewpoint
it looks like an ordinary room.
Another technique we use to estimate distance
is called "Texture Density" and a good example
of it is seen here in this gravel path. Up
close we can see the individual pieces of
gravel and at increasing distance the pieces
of gravel get smaller and smaller in the image.
Up close the texture is quite coarse and as
we go further away the texture becomes finer
and finer, so in our eyes and our brain, we're
looking at the size of a texture and making
some assumptions about how that relates to
distance.
A technique that we use over very, very large
distances is called aerial perspective. This
exploits the fact that objects that are at
large distances of the order of kilometres,
become less distinct; more hazy.
A really important cue is binocular disparity
and we're going to talk much more about it
in this lecture. This is the information that’s
derived from two views of the scene from two
different viewpoints; our left eye and our
right eye and it's a technique that is very,
very widely used in animals.
Our eye contains a lens and is a fairly autonomous
part of our brain is responsible for keeping
that lens focused, so if we're looking at
something that's up close, this part of our
brain is going to adjust the shape of the
lens so that we can focus on that object.
If the object is further away, then the shape
of the lens is going to be changed to focus on that.
We can take information from this muscle and
use that as a proxy for the distance of the
object. There is another fairly autonomous
part of our visual system, which is responsible
for controlling direction in which our eyes
point. When an object is close to our face,
our eyes converge on that particular object.
If we take information about the direction
that are eyes are pointing, we can triangulate to the object and that is a way of inferring its distance.
The final technique that we use is called
"Motion Perspective" and that is as I'm moving
through the world, objects that are close
to me, appear to be moving quite quickly,
whereas objects that are far away, appear
to move much more slowly.